Khloe Kardashian is standing up for her
sister Kim that Kardashian bond is
strong guys after what Instagram user
claimed Kim's youngest child Chicago was
not her biological child Khloe came to
her defense Kim posted the cutest
throwback photo of herself captioned
baby Kate Kylie seemed to think shy is
Kim's look-alike because she wrote under
the photo OMG Chicago they do look a lot
alike I think out of all of her children
shy looks the most like so cute I know
okay so one user disagreed with us all
and stirred up a little bit of drama
online riding Chicago with either look
more like Kanye or the surrogate mom so
someone needed a lesson on what exactly
surrogacy is so Chloe schooled the user
like she does writing your passive wanna
be petty comment is simply uneducated
Chicago is completely Kimberly's
biological child
praise the Lord she was able to have a
surrogate and that we are blessed with
sweet gorgeous shy shy I know way to
tell that troll though it didn't stop
there though of course the user came
back to clarify her comment writing this
I never said the baby wasn't beautiful
but she did have a surrogate okay so
wrong again Chloe ended the argument
writing I am saying you must be more
informed before speaking on something
that you don't know anything about
apparently Chicago is Kimberly's DNA her
and her husband made embryos and then
they were blessed enough to have a
surrogate carry their child for them
since Kimberly is unable to god bless
modern medicine I mean there's the
lesson in itself we love that this
family is so loyal and they stand up for
each other but I think it was very
classy the way it Chloe clap back I do
too I mean and say what you want about
the Kardashians they always have each
other's back and their clap back game is
so strong I love your face out o but
guys do we think Khloe overreacted I
mean talking about someone's baby it's a
really sensitive subject and you do
cross the line let us know what you
think about how she addressed this we
went with
the moment I laid eyes on my baby I so
in love
so before welcoming shy Kym opened up to
ET about her surrogacy experience she
admits she would have prefered carrying
her third child if she wasn't high-risk
knowing that I was able to carry my
first two babies and not you know my
baby now that is hard for me so it's
definitely a harder experience than I
anticipated just in the control area I
cam also recently told ET that they may
not be done having kids man you never
know but I think after that I mean
that's that's a lot three is a lot the
reason you're realizing it's a lot
lately yeah it's you know cuz everyone
needs your attention we would love to
see the Kardashian West family expand I
mean they're huge already let's make it
bigger and when and if they do we'll be
here to break it all down with you
absolutely in the meantime be sure to
subscribe to all things et until next
time we want to keep chatting with you
I'm at Kourtney underscore tezo know and
I'm at Halle underscore Stephen bye for
now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]